and jen ryu making his third start of
the season
as dansby now hits with the bases empty
and one out
90 mile an hour fastball a swing and a
miss two down
so here's ozuna marcel the designated
hitter tonight ryu wants the change
and he threw a beauty what a great pitch
to get him a couple of strikeouts
and nothing across for atlanta the
bottom of the first vladimir guerrero jr
3-1 a fastball hit high in the air out
to center field
backing up in cirte he leaps at the wall
got a glove on it and it glances off the
top of the fence
back down and in play acuna will throw
it back
into the diamond as guerrero took it
deep out to center
right center field where the wall
extends up in front of the bullpen
to 16 feet high it was circled by
inciarte think he was headed towards the
shorter portion of the wall
got back to the higher portion went into
the air the ball hit
off of the fence back into his glove so
it would have been down for a base hit
anyway
guerrero busting it out of the box ends
up at second with a one-out double that
was
tanked there's randall grichik the 3-2
pitch to grichik
a fastball lined into center field down
for a base hit inciarte charging hard
guerrero tiptoes around third base
where he gets the stop sign richik
sizzles one right back
up the middle to put runners on the
corners as danny jansen digs in
and a high breaking ball popped up
shallow right field acuna's got a good
arm
and here comes guerrero to the plate
throw his cut
and vlady will slide in safely and the
blue jays take an early one to nothing
lead
look say what you will about vladimir
guerrero and a lot of people
like to rip on him for being a big guy
he is a
very good athlete now he's not a burner
or anything like that
but he scored on a medium depth fly ball
to ronald the cuny junior right there
and that'll bring up austin reilly who
hit his 20th career homer yesterday
the 2-2 and he has thrown so many good
changeups already tonight and he gets a
strikeout
there of riley here is johan camargo
[Music]
yes he did camargo saying at least
appeal down to first marty foster didn't
even need that
four strikeouts through two innings for
hunjin ryu
now swanson's ready to go too sign from
jansen
a look over at first here it comes it is
swung on and hit in the air to right
field
hit well twisting foul hernandez chasing
it reaches up
jumps right at the foul line
and makes the catch against the wall a
fair ball
tay oscar hernandez took a very
interesting route to that baseball but
reaches up over his head
as he leaps at the wall and takes an rbi
double away
from james b swanson so randall gritshik
the dh
two balls two strikes
on the ground left side camargo cuts it
off second base got the lead runner what
a play
by johann camargo shades of chipper
jones over there
third base with a great stab ranging to
his left
i don't know if chip would have got up
fast enough to throw him out there
great play by johan get that out keep
the runner in first
the 2-2 pitch swung on hit hard on the
ground great stab by bashad
pick it up throw to first on a bounce
and they got him
azuna hits a rocket to the right of beau
bechet
a step put the glove down and pick it up
and fire it across
the diamond and a long hop for vladimir
guerrero jr and in fact he picked it on
a second bounce
a tremendous play by the blue jays
shortstop
and a great pick by the brand new first
baseman
and there's your first out here in the
fourth here's travis narneau
swing and a miss and he gets darno ryu
has
five strikeouts tonight austin reilly
will be the banner blue jays up one to
nothing bottom of the fourth
another change up to get him boy riley
swings and misses it three changes at
six strikeouts for him
richard got him to third and then he
challenged the arm of ronald acuna on
the sac fly
giving this game its only score two two
to both shed
and a breaking ball hit off the end of
the bat to center field and a sliding
attempt but it's in and out of the glove
of inciarte
and bechet is aboard inciarte frustrated
that he couldn't squeeze that one
and a bushette will take it and a two
out base runner for the blue jays as
cabinet biggio comes up
and a base hit into right field for
biggio and this will cash in buchet
as the blue jays take a two to nothing
lead
margot is in the hole here and he has
the pitch check swing at the fastball
it's right there for strike three called
seven punch-outs tonight for hinjon ryu
back into the wine charlie culberson
back-to-back strikeouts by hingin ryu
well he's gotta work in tonight as danny
jansen leads off shane green the third
atlanta pitcher tonight
and a swing and a miss breaking ball got
jansen to cut on
and whiff green's inning starts well
i'll lead off strikeout here's drew rio
for two
[Music]
and another outside corner pitch and
green has two strikeouts in a row
four straight toronto batters have
struck out green's pitch to anthony
alford
it's caught on and missed and green just
struck out the side
the braves bullpen continues to dazzle
hopefully the bats will come to life but
first things first hatch will face
travis darno
who has grounded out and struck out
fly ball to left field feeling for the
wall gorielle
made the catch he picks it off that
yellow line at the top of the wall
lourdes curiel jr with a terrific catch
adam duvall is up he has the atlanta hit
he's also walked
driven toward right that ball's pretty
well hit hernandez going back he turns
that ball
is gone adam duvall with a home run
and the braves are on the board his
second of the year
and the braves are one swing away from
getting it tied
he got a fastball right there
that's what you do fastball up and out
over the plate and adam just puts a good
swing on it and let's carry out of here
and now jansen's out to talk about this
next hit bat adam duvall
[Music]
ground ball to third step on the bag one
across to first
for a double play and the blue jays will
win it
they snapped their three-game losing
streak outstanding job
by the pitching staff tonight and the
blue jays
beat atlanta by a score of 2-1